[Applause]
hi how are you my love
when manny and i first met he was like
you really liked me don't you and i was
like i really
do i do i like i i did i really did i'm
like you like me the best don't you
yeah i felt such a deep connection with
you it was like magnetic
and we went on this great trip together
we went on this whole weekend
doing all things beauty and
um so much fun we really we just uh we
fit together like a little puzzle piece
as soon as we met
yeah well you're such a wonderful person
manny and so talented
when did you first fall in love with
makeup
you know for me i feel like my makeup
journey really started when i was a wee
taut if you will i would watch my mom
glam you know in the morning she would
before she would go to work she would be
glamming in her
beauty room essentially which is her
room and i would just watch her get
ready and it was
so much fun for me and that's kind of
where i found like the love of my beauty
space uh in the beginning um and i
just remember really really really
loving the idea of
someone being able to help someone
transform
to whatever they wanted to be so i
wanted to be able to help people
feel their best and that's exactly like
what i wanted to do
now let's talk about lunar beauty and
you've had this for a while
it's so beautiful this new palette by
the way my new favorite color
is uh the earthbender because i'm such a
fan
of a brown smokey eye and this is a
brown with this incredible aubergine
tint really great for
the green pupils here i mean look at
this component tree too you have this
really
exquisite diamond coming up
in the middle of like this thick
beautiful
sort of acrylic and then yes ombre
and just i'm sorry but that's a color
every woman wants to wear every man is
what are you wearing on your lips manny
i'm wearing aura actually the [ __ ] that
you just pulled out
well that's a perfect segue because we
wanted to play a little game with you
called i spy
where we can show you a close-up of a
celebrity person of notes eye makeup
and you have to try to identify who it
is plus
most importantly if we can get a manny
mua
tip on maybe how to achieve such eye
absolutely i i got you i got you i am a
game player me too in all the right ways
i guess i knew what you meant okay
listen
is it a good way yeah exactly all right
the first photo
i'm gonna guess see for me i think this
eye is nicki minaj's eye i could be
wrong
let's see oh it's perfect you did
brilliantly now
any tip on this eye this kind of look
it's honestly a super easy look what i
would just say just do primer on the
eyes and just add a little bit of shadow
in the beginning part
ombre it into the outer portion it's
actually really not hard looked achieved
i know it looks kind of scary but it
really isn't
it's literally a multi-tonal look with
lashes on
super easy but it looks a little intense
okay
put up the second photo please and hmm
who do you think manny oh honestly i
really
don't know they have a little bit of a
hooded lid
uh well should we reveal
let's reveal i don't know let's reveal
it's gwen stefani gwen what a stunning
vision that she is
i know you said something really
interesting a hooded lid
how does one do a better eye makeup
around a hooded eye
so what i like to do so with hooded lids
that obviously like what it means like
the skin here
falls over a little bit onto your eyelid
so you don't get as much eyelid space
i actually have a hooded lid myself as
you can see my my
lid is right here but it kind of ends
right there
because the skin falls over so what i
like to do is i kind of like just to
cheat the system
i'll put the shadows into the socket of
my eye and not just the skin
to make it look like i have more space
than i really do so that's just a really
easy simple trick just kind of go a
little bit higher than where you think
you would need to go
um into the socket line and just kind of
carve into where you just want to create
your crease
oh i love that okay last photo
whoa oh okay you know what i think
i i feel like this is billy porter
[Applause]
[Music]
a gorgeous golden beautiful moment from
him
now what's the sort of more wearable
version
of this manny because i love this look
absolutely
so for me what i would do for more
wearable version i would just do like a
soft gold on the lid something easy
a little gold in the lid moment and then
adding like maybe one or two little gold
rhinestones whether on the outer corner
out here
or on the brow bone really just advance
up that look
and just give you a little pop of
something without being too aggressive
i'm literally gonna go get some jewels
for my eyes
you should honestly they are so fun i
love
a little jeweled moment all right be
sure
to check out manny's line lunar beauty
which
everybody already loves and knows and
has been really out there for a long
time
and um just marvel at the quality
and the authority that is manny mua
thank you manny so much thank you of
course thank you so much
oh my gosh and by the way this packaging
oh
it's just so amazing and you can go to
our website and we'll link you right
there and have a little page about
you know lunar beauty as well um but uh
thank you so much and manny
thank you
you